bonjour à tous merci nous recevoir voici
les grands titres de cette édition de
l'héroïne dans la cache d'armes de la
forêt de fontainebleau drogue et
terrorisme des liens étroits raymond
barre parle loyauté c'est le maître mot
dans ses rapports entre jacques chirac
sa majorité et lui le lait maternisé
bientôt dans les grandes surfaces
la commission de la concurrence a donné
un avis favorable nouvel épisode de la
guerre des produits parapharmaceutiques
forza italia
ça va bien pour l'italie taux
d'inflation stabiliser un volume des
échanges commerciaux avec la france qui
lui est plutôt favorable
la visite que monsieur michel noir va
effectuer dans ce pays sera très
instructive le ministre du commerce
extérieur est notre invité rugby pour le
zimbabwe c'est raté ils ont rencontré
les français moralité soixante dix à
douze
attention bandits c'est claude lelouch
qui le dit à la fiche de son dernier
film jean yanne patrick bruel et marie
sophie l aile comme lellouche météo
éclaircies du matin chagrin du lendemain
proverbe simonetta qui veut dire en
clair que le ciel se voile par le nord
et que la chaleur finira par nous donner
des orages voilà pour le sommaire de
cette édition est aujourd'hui mardi 2
juin jour de détention supplémentaires
pour les otages français au liban
les diplomates martel fontaine et marcel
carton le journaliste jean paul
kauffmann et notre confrère d'antenne 2
jean louis normandin
quels sont les rapports entre drogue et
terrorisme né rapport très étroit et de
plus en plus évident selon les propres
paroles de monsieur pasqua et cela après
la découverte de 11 kilos de drogue
composé d'un mélange d'héroïne de
morphine et de caféine dans la cache
d'explosifs de la forêt de fontainebleau
patricia et pour les enquêteurs il n'y a
pas de doute cette drogue devaient
servir au financement des terroristes
pendant leur séjour à paris ce n'est pas
la première fois que terrorisme et
drogues sont ainsi liés mais cette fois
ci il y a une preuve
hervé brusini la preuve du lien entre
terrorisme et drogue
l'association de 8 kg 700 de ce ces
quatre qui avait explosé dans paris en
mars et septembre 86 et de plus de 11
kilos d'un mélange de morphine héroïne
et caféine
la drogue une monnaie bien pratique pour
les terroristes
voilà de l'argent qui occupent un faible
volume et qui ne laisse pas de trace
l'effraction révolutionnaires libanaises
de georges ibrahim abdallah agissait
tout autrement
les farl possédait une multiplicité de
comptes bancaires en suisse et dans
toute l'europe
c'est en remontant la filière d'échec
que les policiers avaient découvert les
appartements les planques les complices
ben abdallah à fontainebleau le groupe
des intégristes shit tunisiens et
marocains avaient enterré son trésor de
guerre
expert en explosifs il devait être aussi
grossiste en nokia c2 toute nature
au liban ce lien entre terrorisme et
drogues et choses bien connu c'est
d'ailleurs le seul point sur lequel tout
le monde est d'accord là bas les hommes
du hezbollah pro-iranien cultivent le
pavot dans la békaa libanaise se d'amal
font passer la marchandise en secteur
chrétiens et les chrétiens justement qui
tiennent le port de beyrouth expédie les
précieuses substances vers l'europe
le tout sous l'oeil bienveillant de
quelques responsables syriens les
correspondants de paris ou de berlin
n'ont plus qu'à écouler la morphine ou
l'héroïne sur leur marché local en
sommes à présent les enquêtes conduites
sur les filières de la drogue
permettront peut-être de remonter celles
du terrorisme
soixante-quatre personnes qui
manifestaient hier près de la maison
blanche contre la politique de ronald
reagan en matière de lutte contre le
sida ont été arrêtés par des policiers
portant des gants en caoutchouc
comme vous le verrez dans le reportage
qui va suivre le responsable de la
police interrogé a déclaré qu'il
craignait en cas de fouille de tomber et
éventuellement sur des serein et
ajoutent ils nous nous protégeons pas
simplement contre le sida mais contre
toutes les maladies contagieuses et les
médecins spécialistes du sida à eux ont
beaucoup parlé ces dernières heures des
multiples formes que revêt le virus d'où
la difficulté de mettre au point un
vaccin
au centre des débats également la
progression de la maladie en afrique
lucie soboul dès le début du congrès les
militants homosexuels se sont fait
entendre criant leur hostilité à la
politique reggane hier au bout de leurs
bras de temps carte portant le triangle
rose symbole de la ségrégation les
homosexuels la plupart sont des malades
ils accuseraient gamme de bloquer
certains crédits de recherche sur le
sida et de ne pas suffisamment développé
les essais de nouveaux médicaments
pendant ce temps à l'intérieur les
chercheurs font le point avec
aujourd'hui une certitude plus le temps
passe après l'infection par le virus
plus haut risque d'évoluer vers une
forme grave de la maladie et centaines
de personnes infectées ont été suivis
pendant plusieurs années en amérique au
bout de cinq ans 5 à 10% d'entre elles
seulement avait développé un sida mais
sept ans après elles sont plus de 30 %
la probabilité de développer la maladie
augmente donc nettement avec le temps
les certaine mesure biologiques
permettent semble-t-il de présents à
cette évolution
cette première journée a été aussi
l'occasion d'évoquer la situation
africaine
tous les experts le reconnaissent il y a
urgence à stopper l'extension de la
maladie
un exemple à kinshasa au zaïre 6% de la
population seraient infectés pour les
responsables de l' oms la progression
constante de la maladie dans le monde
entier est inquiétante
en afrique la situation est inquiétante
mais il faut pas oublier l'emploi global
donc il ya des points chauds de cette
aide de cette pandémie
cette épidémie mondiale mais il ne faut
jamais oublier le contexte général c'est
à dire c'est un problème qui touche tous
les continents et que même là où
l'infection semble être moins comme un
flou rare qu'il faut démarrer maintenant
des systèmes et des campagnes pour
éviter la convocation de burgos compte
tenu des délais d'incubation de la
maladie l'om est-ce l'organisation
mondiale de la france et s'attend à ce
que dans les cinq prochaines années le
nombre de cas de sida continue à
augmenter d'ici là où les experts
reconnaître que les meilleures ventes
pour lutter contre le sida demeure
l'information et la prévention
la concurrence entre les grandes
surfaces et les pharmacies suite
nouvelle étape aujourd'hui avec un avis
de principe publié par le conseil de la
concurrence avec la bénédiction
d'edouard balladur qui autorise de fait
la vente de lait infantile aux grandes
surfaces
en effet le ministre de l'économie
estime que la distribution du lait pour
bébé en pharmacie et
anticoncurrentielles fbt et un point de
gagné pour les grandes surfaces elles
doivent pouvoir vendre librement du lait
pour bébé et les fabricants de l'est qui
refuseraient de livrer les hypermarchés
pour distribuer seulement pharmacie
seraient en infraction avec les règles
de la concurrence
cet avis publié par edouard balladur a
de quoi réjouir les grandes surfaces
mammuth notamment qui pour vendre du
lait dans ses rayons depuis un an doit
s'approvisionner à l'étranger
les fabricants français refusent tous
demande le livret et bien nous disons
bravo au conseil de la concurrence car
aujourd'hui il faut peser sur les prix
et on n'y arrivera pas sans concurrence
réelle
dans les faits il faut encore que les
fabricants et notamment les deux plus
gros bsn et nestlé accepte de nous
livrer ce qu'il refuse de faire jusqu'à
aujourd'hui l'avis publié par edouard
balladur n'est qu'un avis de principe
pas de sanction prévue pour les
fabricants alors il n'est pas évident
que cela change de stratégie commerciale
la pression des pharmaciens sur eux est
forte
les pharmaciens revendique la
distribution exclusive du lait maternisé
ce produit selon eux ne peut pas être
vendu n'importe où sans danger le lait
maternisé pour les nourrissons de 0 à 4
ou 2 0 à 6 mois doit être considéré
comme un médicament en effet le lait
maternisé pour ces jeunes nourissons
n'est pas un produit banal et a besoin
bien sûr du conseil du pharmacien pour
être dispensé tout le monde sait qu'un
certain nombre de carences alimentaires
chez le nourrisson peuvent être
corrigées grâce à ce lait maternisé ça
n'est donc pas un produit banal
cet avis restera-t-il lettre morte les
grandes surfaces bien sûr espère que non
d'autant plus qu'un autre avis du
conseil de la concurrence doit paraître
dans quelques semaines relatifs aux
autres produits de parapharmacie
vitamine c test de grossesse notamment
alors vente exclusive en officine au nom
de la santé ou libre concurrence sur des
produits désormais banalisée
la guerre des pharmaciens et des grandes
surfaces a encore plusieurs batailles de
vente elle à montbard est un homme rare
aussi ses déclarations sont-elles suivi
avec beaucoup d'attention et largement
commentés
il était ce matin l'invité de notre
confrère jean pierre elkabbach sur
europe 1 avant de voir sur le fond les
enseignements que l'on peut tirer de ces
propos les voici en quelques têtes de
chapitres patricia trois points surtout
interrogé sur ses relations avec jacques
chirac raymond barre précise nous ne
sommes pas l'un contre l'autre nous
sommes l'un a connu l'un à côté de
l'autre et il affirme qu'il a assuré le
premier ministre de sa loyauté constante
avant le premier tour et d'un soutien
actif si jacques chirac était en tête
pour le deuxième tour des
présidentielles
questionné également sur son relatif
silence monsieur bart s'est dit
déterminé
à ne pas participer à la cacophonie
actuelle enfin à propos du front
national il souhaite que les français ne
se laissent pas égarer par des
propositions sommaire et simpliste nous
sommes pour la marque de messages que
souhaitait faire passer aujourd'hui
l'ancien prémunissent et je suis loyal
envers le premier ministre et sa
majorité et au moment de l'élection
présidentielle il faudra que l'un et
l'autre se comporte de même avec moi
cela dit monsieur bart n'a épargné
personne je dirais mine de rien la
formule est un peu trop forte c'est vrai
qu'il a tenu ce matin comme d'habitude à
à cultiver sa différence sa singularité
mais tout de même il a fait entendre une
autre musique peut-être plus douce pour
la majorité et je crois qu'il faut
retenir la principale information donnée
à europe 1 patricia l'a rappelé le
déjeuner le fameux déjeuner de tête à
tête entre raymond barre et jacques
chirac s'est déroulée dans de très
bonnes conditions et deux hommes ont
conclu un code de bonne conduite pour la
campagne présidentielle
même si raymond barre n'aime pas
l'expression et pour donner l'exemple ce
matin le bon exemple
raymond barre a insisté sur le fait que
le gouvernement allait va dit-il
at il dit dans la bonne direction je
crois qu'on ne peut être plus unitaire
cela dit pourquoi monsieur bartoli t-il
à faire cette mise au point dans ses
rapports avec monsieur chirac n'était
pas claire ce avant non c'était qu'on
peut demander à michel noirey trois cas
une raison qui est évidente
les deux hommes jacques chirac et
raymond barre ont compris que leur
intérêt passer par cette entente
cordiale conclu jeudi dernier à l'hôtel
de ville
ils savent que l'électorat de la
majorité est restée très unitaire veut
l'unité pas forcément l'uniformité
mais l'unité cet électorat se souvient
de la caf fratricide qui s'étaient
produits dans 80 et qui avait coûté très
cher à jacques chirac au premier tour ee
à valéry giscard d'estaing au deuxième
tour si cette guerre recommence en 88
elle coûtera aussi cher à jacques chirac
à raymond barre
c'est ce que les deux hommes ont compris
ils vont donc tenter de se poser en
rivaux pendant cette campagne sans être
pour autant adversaire l'exercice sera
difficile si vous le permettez ya tout
de même une autre raison moins avouable
en tout cas inavoués elle s'appelle si
j'ose dire
françois léotard le ministre de la
culture jeune sémillant ambitieux pour
l'être en politique sans monter en lui
une envie irrépressible d'être candidat
à la présidence et il le fait savoir
s'il va jusqu'au bout de sa démarche
il viendra forcément raymond barre mais
aussi jacques chirac et montbard parce
que les deux hommes font partie de
l'année
famille udf jacques chirac parce que
françois léotard peut mordre sur une
partie de l'électorat fpr qui résistent
ou qui ne veut pas d'une dérive
droitière à l'image toujours de michel
noir alors du coup des deux anciens
premiers ministres ont senti le danger
c'est la raison pour laquelle ils se
sont rencontrés
c'est à leurs yeux le moyen de parer ce
danger en déjeunant en tête à tête
en scellant un pacte de non agression
ils ont voulu apparaître comme les deux
seuls candidats légitimes de la majorité
ils ont voulu signifier à françois
l'état qui ne pouvait y avoir de
troisième
ils ont en quelque sorte marquer leur
territoire mauvais dit recommander aux
politiques est une sorte d'entente
objective entre ces deux hommes entre le
club des grands très bien vous avez
voyagé soit un petit détail avec les
notables lyonnais ils se comprennent
monsieur mermaz monsieur bah pas
monsieur noir vous étiez déjà là c'était
ils se parlent entre eux ou pas ils se
saluent
ils se savaient ils se parlent très
brièvement et ensuite ils s'ignorent
dans le wagon monsieur noir on va en
profiter puisque nous parlions de lyon
de monsieur bardot politique à propos du
mot cacophonie dans la majorité
récemment vous sentez causé concernés
par cette appréciation
parce que je crois c'est qu'aujourd'hui
chacun de façon la plus claire ce qui
est souhaitable et souhaitée par
l'immense majorité des français dit les
choses très clairement sur les valeurs
auxquelles on croit ça c'est ça
l'essentiel non ce qui est ce qui vient
d'être dit paraît ce pacte de non
agression comme dit paul amar c'est
quelque chose que vous approuvez à tout
à fait parce que ce qui est tout à fait
fort dans l'électorat majoritaire jeudi
aux mêmes heures or au delà
j'ai beaucoup de français c'est qu'il ya
un besoin d'union les français se
souviennent qu'en 80 on n'avait pas été
très très effrayant et par convient
souviennent que l'union mais très bien
marché en 86 que ça soit listes séparées
côte à côte nous a souvent liste commune
ça avait très bien marché ce qui
explique qu'on avait gagné donc il est
tout à fait naturel que ce sentiment est
en très fort les grands candidats comme
vous les appelez est le souci de
répondre à cette aspiration des
électeurs qui je le rappelle est très
forte a mentionné une question politique
mais on reviendra après sur votre
domaine qui nous intéresse plus
particulièrement aujourd'hui c'est à
dire le commerce extérieur
vous êtes satisfait des propos de
monsieur bart sur le front national sur
monsieur le pen sait pas qu'il est tout
à fait clair c'est au niveau des valeurs
auxquelles on croit ce triptyque liberté
tolérance respect de la personne humaine
qui ne serait faire l'objet de
transactions c'est je crois une
affirmation très forte et c'est celle
que je crois que sa teinte où les
démocrates ont énoncé
eh bien nous y vivons rester avec nous
parce que cette fois ci on va parler de
commerce alors michel noir en italie dès
cet après midi vous y rester deux jours
et demi presque trois jours
le ministre du commerce extérieur vaty
s'inspirer des méthodes de nos voisins
mais nous le dira dans un instant car en
italie ça va beaucoup mieux un exemple
parmi d'autres janvier 1986 l'inflation
était de 6 et demi pour cent
actuellement le taux annuel dans ce pays
tourne autour de 4,2 ce qui plutôt bien
et selon un rapport de l' ocde
l'italie est passée devant la
grande-bretagne au rang des grandes
puissances économiques et nous talonne
et à symbole du nouveau dynamisme des
italiens c'est tout simplement la
réussite des entreprises et surtout la
popularité la nouvelle popularité des
patrons en italie voici l'exemple d'une
femme qui est à la tête du téléphone
italien a écrit dans son pays est
devenue une star si que la presse
italienne décrit marisa bellisario une
top managers à la tête de la plus grande
entreprise italienne de téléphone ital
tel célèbres comme une star de cinéma
mari ça vient juste
écrire ses mémoires avec photos d'elle
au verso dans son conseil
d'administration avec son chien
ce livre qui s'intitule femmes et top
managers est aujourd'hui un best-seller
en italie une histoire est très
inhabituel elle l'a toujours été
je me suis toujours occupé de
technologie je vis dans le monde de
l'électronique international depuis
longtemps et j'ai pensé qu'il était
intéressant de raconter à travers la
renaissance d'une entreprise publique
ital tél en fait c'est l'histoire d'une
femme qui a fait une carrière d'homme
enfin ce que l'on considère normalement
comme une carrière dans cette usine du
groupe i talk est l'âme il en fabrique
des centraux téléphoniques
ici la machine à remplacer l'homme la
reconversion façon bellisario s'est
traduite par une baisse des effectifs
d'un bon tiers 29 1000 employés en 1981
17700 aujourd'hui trois cadres
dirigeants sur cinq ont été remplacés
résultat le chiffre d'affaires a doublé
en 5ans et l'entreprise qui accumulait
les déficits est aujourd'hui
bénéficiaire
un succès dû en grande partie selon
marissa bellisario ou climat de
confiance qui règne aujourd'hui en
italie italiana duke mes années ces
risques en italie ces dernières années
on a redécouvert le capitalisme
l'entreprise
on a redécouvert aussi le profit la
productivité et l'efficacité et dans les
années 70 on expliquer aux étudiants que
le profil était négatif que toutes les
valeurs traditionnelles du capitalisme
étaient des valeurs négatives
et bien maintenant tout cela a changé
parce que la gauche a changé en italie
c'est la présence des socialistes dans
le gouvernement qui a donné au pays sa
stabilité
sur les traces de la signora bellisario
des femmes commencent à faire carrière
dans le monde impitoyable du management
en accumulant les succès un signe parmi
d'autres du nouveau visage de l'économie
italienne via alors monsieur le ministre
la réussite industrielle et commerciale
dans un pays ça dépend bon c'est une
question de structure une question de
loi je trouve qu'en dit allez les
structures sont friables et loire le
respecte plus ou moins est ce que par
hasard ça serait pas investi une
question d'hommes et de femmes qui
viennent de voir avec cette dame on de
dire c'est surtout une affaire de punch
de caractère de gens qui vont vite créer
de gérer d'avancé de réussir et ce qui
est frappant dans cette réussite
italienne où sont pas encore juste
derrière nous ils sont quatre cinquièmes
de nous donc il ya encore un petit peu
de marge mais ce qui est admirable
leur réussite est fondée sur la
créativité on savait qu'ils sont très
créatifs mais aussi une extraordinaire
capacité de management et d'ouverture à
l'international ils sont allés sur les
marchés hors pair il est leur balance
pratiquement sont toutes positives sur
leurs principaux concurrents mais encore
là où nous avons nous des progrès à
faire et je les rencontre sur tous les
grands marchés où je vais mais on garde
pays par mois à chaque dans chaque pays
je vois des italiens très bien placé
compétitif présents dont ils sont bons
mais ça dérange pas d'en haut ça veut
dire c'est pas le ministre du commerce
extérieur italien qui leur a dit chers
amis forêt
remuer tout à fait c'est eux qui ont
décidé ça alors vous pouvez insisté les
industriels français
de quelle manière bon moi je peux dire
d'abord priorité européenne n'ont pas
seulement parce ya l'échéance 92 parce
que nous avons nous sommes en situation
à plus de vulnérabilités des déficits
importants vis-à-vis de l'allemagne de
l'italie et de l'espagne puis j'étais
aussi arrêtons un petit peu le tourisme
exotique à vingt mille kilomètres de là
sur des marchés qui existe à plein avec
des clients qui payent pas autant aller
sur ces pays européens qui sont tout
près d'ici
sur lequel il ya des tas de choses à
faire c'est l'étape déficit de la
redresser
puisque vous parlez de l'europe il
semble que les français dans certains
domaines sont pénalisés un exemple il y
a plus de charge plus de taxes qui
pèsent sur les entreprises françaises le
fioul lourd par exemple sur leurs
partenaires européens alors est-ce que
vous pouvez vous engager à baisser ses
taxes comme vous d'ivoire l'udf par
exemple ce qui est vrai c'est que ces
dernières années on a un peu trop
charger la barque des entreprises qui si
aujourd'hui elles ont décroché un petit
peu sont moins compétitifs que leurs
concurrentes c'est parce qu'elles n'ont
plus de charges
vous le savez le gouvernement à faire un
premier première série dans le cadre du
budget 87 d'allègements de charges
sensible puisque entre les éléments de
charges emploi plus les diminutions
d'impôts ça fait un premier paquet de 25
milliards et d'asnières 24 milliard et
demi monsieur balladur annoncé déjà donc
c'est pratiquement grand public ils se
comptaient l'espérait présenté pour les
prochaines un même paquet d'allègements
ce qui devrait permettre à nouveau à nos
entreprises de rattraper ce retard de
compétitivité mais il faut la durée si
on ne change pas les choses du jour au
lendemain il faut de la dur et
persévérer et c'est surtout une affaire
de mentalité comme je disais à l'instant
où il
je crois que c'est vraiment celle
obtenue c'est dans la tête et dans le
coeur celle a envie de se défoncer à
l'étranger de sortir son petit hexagone
et de s'apercevoir que l italique et
c'est le milan est plus près de lyon que
que neil de lyon donc plus de frontières
janin on est tout de même monsieur le
ministre depuis qu'il est arrivé au
pouvoir vous accorder un certain nombre
de choses d'entreprise la liberté
liberté des prix du gaz et des changes
liberté de licencier les exonérations de
charges sociales de chlore dans le même
temps le commerce extérieur français
s'est dégradée alors comment expliquer
cette contradiction que je disais à
l'instant je crois qu'il faut un certain
temps fait il ya une séquence qui est
très claire tout d'abord ce assainir
financièrement beaucoup d'entreprises
étaient un peu en état de leucémie c'est
plus de dette que de ressources pour
financer le futur pour investir en
sommes en réseaux commerciaux
il faut ensuite voir investir en sommes
mais aussi en recherche
il faut ensuite investi en réseaux
commerciaux aller à l'étranger
donc cette séquence elle prend du temps
je crois que nous sommes dans les jeunes
je le constate mme aubry chiffres si
aujourd'hui les chiffres sont mauvais du
commerce extérieur c'est parce qu'on
achète de plus en plus d'équipements à
l'étranger on est sur une pente de plus
10%
ça c'est superbe comme dans l'ordre
ailleurs ce qu'ils règlent leurs comptes
définitifs à la fausse querelle de
l'aide officielle à la justice
est ce que le problème de fond c'est pas
un problème culturel les produits
français sont passés bien adaptés sont
non pas une qualité suffisante l épreuve
des délais les entreprises sont pas
assez présentes comme vous avez raison
de dire on accélère on a eu certaines
faiblesses qu'on est en train de
peut-être de rattraper notre culture
était insuffisamment tournées sur
l'international on pensait trouve
hexagone et deuxièmement on n'était pas
habitué à sept frères rigueur
extraordinaire du marché allemand par
exemple du défaut zéro et on a beaucoup
de progrès à faire pour presque
l'automobile française est en train
d'éclater en ce moment je fais une
superbe performance y compris sur le
marché allemand c'est parce qu'on nous
sommes habitués au niveau des
constructeurs automobiles mais c'est
vrai dans d'autres secteurs industriels
c'est pour ça qu'il faut être optimiste
on s'est habitué à cette rigueur
extraordinaire au niveau du qualité zéro
défaut que ça soit dans le produit pour
la facture pour la prévente pour la
prospection
c'est le professionnel souhaite des pros
pour réussir c'est comme au football
poitou
tennis fois le super pro pour réussir
dans un univers de compétition où c'est
la finale roland garros tous les jours
bien mais justement on en parlera total
un merci monsieur le ministre
procès barbie suite de l'audition des
témoins propos de la rafle d'izieu
on entendra la barre aujourd'hui entre
autres le prix nobel de la paix elie
wiesel
l'écrivain doit parler cet après-midi de
toute l'horreur du nazisme
deux mamans seront également là pour
dire leur désespoir leur enfant était à
izieu et ils sont morts à auschwitz
paul de faire l'audience d'aujourd'hui
s'annonce difficile
lourde d'émotion comme chaque jour
l'huissier de justice va se rendre à la
prison saint joseph pour sommer barbie
de comparaître
comme chaque jour celui ci va refuser de
venir à premier réflexion je ne pense
pas que le président s'est redit ni le
fasse venir de force aujourd'hui
audience difficile donc car vont venir
déposer plusieurs femmes dont les
enfants se trouvaient à izieu tout elles
ont été déportés certaines d'entre elles
n'ont appris la disparition de leur
enfant qu'à leur retour des camps
d'autres comme celle ci madame benguigui
ont découvert là-bas dans des
circonstances dramatiques la mort de ses
enfants qu'elle croyait en sécurité à
izieu sur un jeune déporté
elle a reconnu le pull-over d'un de ses
trois enfants
j'étais au boulot midi show l'homme
d'expérience ils ont fait du vexin sur
moi et alors j'évite encore le culot
verges je m'approche puis je le touche
il m'a regardée alors j'ai dit il
comprenait pas le français
pour l'onu ou en russe alors je le
regardais et chaque fois que monter
pendant trois jours je le regardais
alors je me faisais de mauvaises idées j
dc ça y est un plus mais enfants autre
témoin et non des moindres aujourd'hui
élise elle le prix nobel de la paix
arrivé il ya quelques instants s'est
d'abord recueilli devant le mémorial est
levé sur la place des terreaux à la
mémoire des victimes de la déportation
mais je suis pas moi un chasseur de
nazis dont je ne suis pas un mangeur
je ne crois pas à la vengeance que je
crois à la justice
je crois à la justice trois mémoires
le geste est sans mémoire de passer ici
maintenant avion dans votre esprit
copé ou dans votre capital en effet il
ya
c'était ce qui a fait qu'ils vous qui
est important qu'ils étaient évitables
d'associer assortissent justice à la
mémoire
le premier ministre libanais monsieur
karam est assassiné hier et dans la
soirée c'est le ministre du travail
monsieur sélim hoss qui a été nommé pour
assurer l'intérim c'est un homme de
confession sunnite comme le veut la
tradition politique dans ce pays le
poste de premier ministre est toujours
occupée par un musulman sunnite et déjà
trois revendications de cet assassinat
de au liban une à paris toute la
population libanaise aujourd'hui
observent une grève générale en signe de
deuil philippe gassot il n'aura fallu
que quelques heures après l'assassinât
de rachid karamé pour qu'un ministre
soit désigné par le président de la
république libanaise afin de ne pas
laisser vacant le poste de président du
conseil le ministre désigné pour assurer
l'intérim selim al noces et sunnites
comme le veut la constitution dans le
gouvernement karameh il occupait le
poste de ministre du travail
il assumera la fonction de président du
conseil en attendant que soit formé un
nouveau gouvernement au moment où
tripoli la grande ville sunnite du nord
ri bord un hommage celui qu'on appelle
par respect les fendi un titre de
noblesse ottoman la grève générale est
respectée ici comme à beyrouth
l'assassinât sera lui revendiqué par
téléphone dans la capitale libanaise
deux communications émanant de deux
organisations encore inconnue s'attribue
le meur l'armée secrète du liban et
l'organisation de la vengeance des
martyrs de l'islam
c'est probablement la même faction qui
ce matin a fait parvenir un texte à la
fp à paris revendiquant l'assassinât
selon la lettre manuscrite écrites en
arabe la mort de rachid karamé serait
lié au meurtre de 300 libanais tué par
l'armée syrienne
en décembre 86 ici à tripoli après une
opération menée contre les intégristes
religieux l'actualité à l'étranger
toujours les autorités allemandes
condamne la violation de l'espace aérien
soviétique mais en allemagne le jeune
pilote mathias est considéré comme un
héros je vous rappelle qu'il s'est posé
sur la place rouge en chine lincendie
reprend dans le nord-est du pays le feu
avance de 20 kilomètres par heure et les
flammes atteignent 20 mètres de haut et
puis une rectification avant
notification le château dauzac de
margaux n'est pas en vente c'est une
information qui ont été données par
erreur au cours d'un reportage sur le
château citran qui lui a été vendu aux
japonais c'est le propriétaire des fêtes
aussi temps qui avait dit ça bah il
s'est trompé at attendant n'est pas à
vendre
qu'on se le dise d'amour se maintenant
avec jean-claude heureux non c'est
surtout préoccupés aujourd'hui à la
bourse des mouvements du dollar jean
claude et bien effectivement une fois de
plus ici la vedette c'est le dollar qui
perd plus de 6 centimes à 6 francs 05 75
il était monté trop vite et sans raison
estiment les professionnels aussi
indécente il aujourd'hui
en fait le billet vert cherche ses
marques à quelques jours du sommet de
venise cette rechute du dollar provoque
au sein du système monétaire européen
un léger affaiblissement du franc
français notamment par rapport aux deux
marques qui est aujourd'hui à 3 33 75
fermeté du franc suisse à 4 03 85 et
bonne résistance du yen japonais à 419
voilà pour les monnaies à la bourse des
valeurs l'indicateur de tendance affiche
maintenant -0 35% dans un marché peu
actif
un incident technique m'empêche de vous
donner une sélection des baisses les
plus importantes mais vous pourrez les
retrouver tout à l'heure sur votre
minitel en tapant le 36 15 codes aequo à
2 sur le marché de l'or le lingot d'un
kilo gagne 50 fonds à 87 1950 le
napoléon lui gagne 4 francs à 529 voix
la chute du billet du billet vert à
paris le dollar perd plus de 6 centimes
merci jean claude rugby maintenant coupe
du monde en nouvelle zélande comment va
la france serait bien ça va toujours
très bien pour la france
soixante dix à douze contre le zimbabwe
en revanche cela va plutôt mal pour erik
bonneval qui lui souffre du genou fou
thierry blancot 16e minute premières
images fortes la sortie d' eric bonneval
diagnostic entorse au niveau de la tête
du péroné coupe du monde fini pour lui
bonneval s'est blessé sur cette action
crochet intérieur et percussions dans le
pack du zimbabwe le zimbabwe qui avait
ouvert la marque sur cette pénalité dès
le début du match
grobler une pénalité consécutive à un
hors jeu français
ensuite c'est un véritable festival du
quinze de france surtout en deuxième mi
temps 9 essais en 25 minutes
le premier de la série modin pour la
porte
andrieu à l'intérieur pour denis charvet
qui transperce littéralement la défense
du zimbabwe france 28 zimbawé 3 la mêlée
française domine rodriguez pour mme
audin cambérabéro petit côté pour finir
c'est son premier essai et déjà sa
septième transformation une minute plus
tard superbe attaque des tricolores mode
important berhabe héros qui lui redonne
à l'intérieur cambérabéro à nouveau
rodriguez la porte andrieu et le tgv
esther pour terminer france 56 mbao et 3
ils peuvent être contents ces supporters
français car ça n'est pas finie
cambérabéro marque sur cette action son
troisième essai et surtout son 30e
points en match international un record
mondial vient de tomber celui de son
père guy cambérabéro score final france
70 zimbabwe 12 tennis maintenant les
internationaux de france à roland garros
journée calme pour le coeur le moral des
français
noah c'est demain et puis ce matin y
avait l'un d'eux gomes un direct de
roland garros daniel cazals sous la
pluie ou sous le soleil
non non sur le soleil et sous même à un
parasol est actuellement est bien sur le
central lundi les gomez sont opposés
essai
gomez qui sert et les deux joueurs sont
à 4 jeux partout et gomez est menée sur
son service
15-40 autrement dit ce sont là deux
balles de break au bénéfice du
tchécoslovaque 30 40 grâce à mon service
c'est la seizième fois que les deux
joueurs se rencontrent je dois lire
qu'une seule fois andres gomez est
parvenu à battre ivan lendl c'était en
1981 à washington c'est la troisième
fois que gomez arrive en quarts de
finale à roland garros et les deux fois
précédentes il a été battu justement par
ivan lendl 40 partout il faut signaler
également que ce sont presque deux
jumeaux que vous voyez à évoluer sur le
central car ils ont huit jours d'écart
exactement ils sont de 60 tous les deux
gomez et du 27 février et ivan lendl et
du 3 mars si je me rappelle bien alors
voyez ils sont vraiment très très près
alors se fait à peu près cinq jours
avantage gomez une balle de 5 jeux à 4
pour le gaucher qui est un garçon qui au
tour précédent a réussi à sauver une
balle de match contre l'espagnol emilio
sanchez gomez qui a gagné un tournoi
cette année c'était le tournoi de forest
hills où il avait battu quand même boris
becker et puis yannick noah en finale
quant à ivan lendl il a gagné également
un tournoi c'était à hambourg en battant
le tchécoslovaque miloslav mecir
institut national temps d'aller jusqu'à
la fin du jeu de jeu finalement un petit
peu sur yannick ouimet oui je
préférerais bon alors on va revenir un
petit peu sur wii car chez le premier
set alors on a encore le temps même si
un set et pris par gomez ou par lendl
alors si vous le voulez on revient un
petit peu en arrière on revient en
arrière pour voir comment yannick s'est
sorti des griffes de ce petit suédois
kent carlson qui est classé 11e mondiale
mais dont yannick dit qu'il vaut
vraiment la 5e place sur terre battue et
là nous sommes à deux sets zéro pour
noah et grâce à cela plus
la tension sociale la possibilité de
jouer un tie break ce sera le deuxième
tie-break de la journée et la grâce à un
retour gagnant et bien c'est carlson qui
empêche la manche et noah mène deux sets
à un
il doit sauver deux balles de match
avant de gagner deux balles de set
warburg balles de deux sets partout
avant de gagner sept jeux à sac dans la
quatrième manche du côté yannick il est
difficile un jour où il a des balles
très liftées c'est le joueur qu'il est
le plus donc les trajectoires de balle
sont vraiment particulier donc
aujourd'hui ajoute à ça le fait il a
joué assez long je dois pour moi c'était
très difficile de venir à la volée parce
qu'il fallait que je fasse peut-être les
demi douzaine de coups au fond du court
à gauche à droite avant de monter à la
volée alors monter un vrai dans ces
conditions pour se prendre un passing
lifté d'un lob lifté de la cité c'était
vraiment pas simple voilà merci daniel
on vous retrouve demain journée
importante comme nous le disions au
début maintenant nous allons parler de
bain de cinéma contre le déni qui
connaît bien claude lelouch pour l'avoir
filmé souvent attention bandits c'est le
titre de ce film qui sort demain juste
avant la fête du cinéma et vous vivez
aujourd'hui les affres de la paternité
est encore plus terrible demain mais
vous avez l'habitude alors on parlera du
film on va parler de la santé du cinéma
rapidement en france et puis on parlera
des finales temps des rapports
relativement orageux entre la télévision
et le cinéma j'en sais quelque chose
alors parlons d'abord du film c'est un
film d'aventuré d'amour avec de grands à
je peux dire un
oui il régler l'histoire qui est dans le
développement et est simple un vous
renouvelle avec une tradition qu'il
arrive on capote flash backs est une
histoire droite c'est une histoire
il ya une véritable continuité mais
c'est un film qui est traitée en comédie
sur un sujet quand même grave que sont
les nouveaux bandits qu ils sont là ils
existent et pour pas trop faire peur on
les a traités un petit peu comme ça sous
forme d'un film d'aventurés un petit peu
comme l' aventure celle aventure alors
c'est comme la bande à bono à l'époque
avait innové vous pensez qu'il y a des
nouveaux bandits aujourd'hui oui les
nouveaux bandits parce que avant les
bandits venait de classe sociale disons
plus défavorisés et maintenant on les
recrute même chez les gens qui ont fait
des études qui sont de très très bons
techniciens car le banditisme aussi la
barre elle monte les moyens de
prévention sont de plus en plus serré
donc c'est normal que les bandits
deviennent de plus en plus performants
alors ça c'est aussi un des thèmes
importants du film et les bandits
d'aujourd'hui sont un petit peu plus
intelligent qu'avant donc ils vont être
un peu plus dur à arrêter donc attention
bandits alors les bandits ce sont jean
yanne patrick bruel votre ami charles
gérard et probablement quelques autres
et puis il ya une jeune fille pure c'est
marie sophie wii et qui elle est là la
fille de l'un d'eux de jean yanne en
particulier il a préservé sa fille en la
mettant à l'abri pendant une dizaine
d'années par un temps où il était à
l'ombre à fresnes faire exactement mis à
l'abri dans une pension chics et chers
en suisse c'est ça ces tensions existent
sont des pensions fabrique des jeunes
filles qu'on vous rend clé en main ce
sont des pensions de princesse pour
personne très très fortunés et ces
jeunes filles sont préparés a rencontré
ensuite les messieurs qui à travers le
monde ont des postes importants mais il
ya des bandes et mais pas des bandits
qui fait qu'au moment où elle retrouve
son père elle tend effectivement sur un
individu dont on lui avait donné aucune
référence et l on tombe forcément elle
est un décalage pour avec la plus
compliquée elle arrive d'un monde où la
culture domine et là elle arrive dans le
monde de l'instant où toutes les
réactions effectivement sont instinctive
et beaucoup plus sexy beaucoup plus
intéressante aux petits dire alors on va
voir quelques images de ce fils alors je
voudrais tout de suite précisé que vous
savez qu'il ya des spécialités et par
exemple je parlais de vos collègues jean
pierre melville était un homme qui fuit
mais très bien les cas bars et les
boîtes de nuit
claude sautet si les bistrots les
bistrots de copains de claude sautet
c'est très bien vous c'est les scènes de
repas
quand vous êtes champion du monde dans
la catégorie sous le nom vous
souvenons nous d'un homme et d'une femme
où on avait pensé à l'époque c'était
improvisé pas du tout c'était au
contraire très bien travaillé d'allant
là nous avons pris précisément une
semaine de repos indique les gens se
mettent à table comme vous dites et ben
voilà alors voilà voix mais sans cette
séquence époux
quartier fruits
c'était pas pu faire face à la crise
quand je ne suis pas vu non plus il m'a
sauté dans la main j'étais dans un état
second et a pas moins pour moi tu es
déçu par ton papa donc bondi de filtre
de la pensée sept bandits écrire un
livre et si le naturel revient au galop
non là je t'en supplie il n'y a pas de
gentils bandits non mais
je suis pas un vrai dandy et puis j'ai
pas vraiment nos pieds
est-ce que c'était truqué
pourquoi manger une brêle qu'est ce qui
est formidable c'est quelle que soit
avec aux médias que j'avais fait
travailler ils s'adaptent tous au
système lellouche et notamment dans ces
scènes de repas où ils ont l'air aussi
naturel que notre cousin où notre temps
à table c'est tout à fait étonnante et
ça faisait 20 ans que j'attendais
josiane c'était un rêve j'ai à
travailler ensemble 25 ans chez gérard
cyr oui c'est nier toute humilité tout
une petite bande et j'avais toujours dit
à jean le jour où j'aurai un très très
grand rôle j'ai un vrai devoir voilà
j'ai attendu un quart de siècle alors à
claude lelouch j'ai entendu des metteurs
en scène qui avait l'air de penser
qu'ils étaient des metteurs en scène
maudit par la faute de la critique et et
d'autres choses mais alors vous si vous
écoutiez la critique il ya longtemps que
vous n'existerez y ait pu alors vous
l'écoutez dans les limites raisonnables
et puis après on pense à autre chose
donc je pense que c'est un jeu ça fait
partie du jeu je me suis jamais insurgé
contre les mauvaises critiques
c'est ce qui est peut-être ma force j'en
ai souffert parce que personne ne peut
ne pas souffrir des horreurs que les
critiques sont capables de dire sur vous
mais je fais confiance je sais pas je
suis patient voilà je suis patient et
contre les critiques c'est une arme
formidable très bien et la télé et le
cinéma c'est un mariage heureux que
voudrait vieux qui vivent chacun chez
eux
donc c'est un mariage qui n'a pas encore
trouvé ses marques en ce sens que les
gens adorent le cinéma de plus en plus
et je regrette qu'ils aiment de plus en
plus devant leur télévision c'est pour
ça qu'il ya cette fête du cinéma c'est
pas pour pousser les gens qui vont au
cinéma au cinéma cela ils vont à la fête
toutes les semaines mais c'est pour ce
jeu ne devons jamais et il faut que les
gens sachent que voir un signe dans une
grande salle où le voir devant sa télé
c'est comme envoyer lettre vous
rencontrez quelqu'un voyez il ya une
grande différence
alors ça c'est important que les gens
aillent au cinéma ça n'a rien à voir
avec ce qu'ils voient devant leur petit
écran qu'il avait une sorte de truc pour
réviser les films c'est vrai cela du
crepac une querelle moyenâgeuse c'est
comme s'il y avait un charron
aujourd'hui qu'il y avait qui disait au
conducteur du tgv dit dont vous mais
piquer mes clients c'est une autre
époque où ils vont sans maintenance et
public qu'il faut éduquer c'est pas la
télé cinéma unités au vivre ensemble
télévision et cinéma j'espère que vous
appelez moi j'ai toujours été un adepte
des deux toujours tous avec il
dernier en 84 1 milliard 400 millions de
téléspectateurs de spectateurs de cinéma
aux états unis et la télévision ça
existe là bas depuis 40 ans et plus soit
ils exigent une chance folle c'est que
tous les films qui passent à la télé
sont alors regardable on les coupe
toutes les cinq minutes
nous on n'a pas encore cette chance à
ben voilà ce qu'il faut faire alors très
bien je signale que vous êtes aussi le
président du festival national de la
jeunesse c'est bien ça c'est du 14 au 21
juin ça se passera à paris alléger ses
amis tâche fois qu'on reparle le saint
geours comptons en bas mercredi qui en
parlera de la jeunesse d'accord pour ne
vous dit rien pour ce film je fais des
comme ça fasse des bois et patricia des
choses à vous dire à propos du grand
prix des lectrices de elle oui ce grand
prix couronne de livres d'abord un roman
de chacun allégé 22 avec ce très beau
livre sur l'histoire du la montée du
nazisme en allemagne dans les années 40
à travers la vie d'une famille
couronnement également pour la série
documents de ce livre très bien fait
aussi de françoise wagner une très belle
biographie de madame récamier voilà donc
pour le grand prix des lectrices de elle
merci patriciens la météo maintenant
avec brigitte simonetta pour terminer
cette édition moi j'ai toute une vie
pour comprendre les secrets du ciel
alors c'est du beau tort aujourd'hui
mais voilà ça ne va pas durer nous
allons tout de suite regardé la carte de
cet après midi
beau temps certes avec de belles
éclaircies sur toute la moitié sud avec
du beau temps de belles éclaircies
également des pays de la loire au centre
et jusqu'à l'est mais une perturbation
qui arrive qui voile de plus en plus le
ciel qui recouvre de plus en plus les
éclaircies surtout le nord-ouest et ses
nuages finiront par donner quelques
ondées
demain ce sera mauvais pratiquement
partout c'est à dire que cette
perturbation continuera son chemin elle
recouvrira toute la moitié du pays elle
donnera de la pluie sous forme d'averses
du sud ouest au bassin parisien et au
nord-est sous forme de plus continues
sur les côtes de la manche et en fin
d'après-midi alors à même recouvert le
sud-est et la corse alors qu'il y aura
dans l'après midi quelques éclaircies
les températures en revanche sont en
hausse il fait chaud et fait même lourd
de 16 à 25 degrés sur la moitié nord
avec un maximum à bourges
et sur la moitié sud de 23 à 28 degrés
maximum animaux il fait trop lourd et ça
se terminera en or h il 24° j'ai vu
d'ailleurs votre bras
à saint-jean-de-luz et bien s'il pleut
demain elle est donc au cinéma ça sera
bien pour le cinéma et pour le film de
claude lelouch entre autres au revoir à
tous merci de nous avoir reçus passer un
bon après midi et à demain 13h pour
d'autres informations
à